[Music]
this little reunion about to crack we
got the whole crew back really [__] a
cabin in the woods got Miss kitted all
that perspective for all y'all enjoyment
you still a slave to the white man I'm
gonna stop calling my wife the white man
all right
oh hell no where are you going look for
the fuse box what kind of house is this
[Applause]
this [__] probably runs on racism
refused to play and she dies
I think we have to play the game
in your predicament the black character
is always the first to die I will spare
your lives if you sacrificed the person
you deemed the blackest to blackest
nobody used to judge anybody in here bro
you have two minutes to decide
y'all can't pick me I'm gay oh Clifton
yeah that can prove him not the blackest
prove it I've never seen Friday
I voted for Trump
what
twice
up we need a plan don't say don't you
dare don't say this don't see it we have
to split up
[Applause]
your time has run out it's time to die
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a crazy person oh yeah
we should be sitting down right now I
mean
that's exactly what she did
what made you look
my black women gotta save everyone
others
you know stop playing
I got a gun
that's too DMX what are you doing
[Music]
thank you